[Music]
having your wrist I fell down
Carrie Underwood sat down with I heart
radios Bobby bones show in Nashville on
Thursday and opened up about the
accident that left her with a broken
wrist and 40 to 50 stitches in her face
last November I was taking the dogs out
to OPP one last time and I just I
tripped
there was one step and I went to I
didn't let go of the leashes priorities
so that's why my left hand is fine but I
went to catch myself and I just missed a
step the singer stayed out of the public
eye for months after her nasty spill
explaining on her website quote when I
am ready to get in front of a camera I
want you all to understand why I might
look a bit different where did you fall
on your face like a side of your face oh
yeah you just don't know how things are
gonna heal or end up the 35 year old
made her first public appearance at the
ACM Awards where she performed her new
song cry pretty
[Music]
but decided to skip the red carpet it's
not like we definitely wanted to keep
everything music focused and the Grammy
winner revealed the adorable way her
three-year-old son Isaiah with husband
Mike Fisher reacted to her accident for
for a while I was worried he would be
scared of me but now if I put makeup on
he's like mommy your boo-boos all gone
[Music]